[Music]
hello
felix just gonna fully just cut that out
phil already welcome to youtube's
favorite show
they're really simple if you laugh you
lose
and you can't do either one of them
challenge
accepted by leaving a like on this video
right now
yo we sold it i'm so there right now
okay okay okay
[Music]
bish that did not even close to rhyme
what the
actual fury are you trying to say
love the tune though it's hella lit we
sold it
right now
[Applause]
all right now let's move on it's hard to
just sleep when you're tired because
people are tired most of the time
i love you so much oh thanks can't give
you a hug no thanks please
no thanks yeah no thanks
i don't know who that was yeah you did
jerry come on oh brilliant oh thanks
please
no thanks yeah no thanks
i like how jerry is still living on in
the seinfeld show
in real life and as always brofist
everyone
oh my god
me bro footing a picture of pewdiepie
for 12
minutes and 29 seconds
well it looks like my job here is done
this video will now play on
for the rest of the video enjoy
it for low rider i have literally
anything else to do
i'm joking i'm joking stop crying
does he actually though oh my god
i'm losing brain cells every second
let's move on we so lit
dab like this it's catchy
shut up it's catchy like kesha okay
all right i'm sure you've seen this
playlist on youtube called
instant regret clicking this playlist
parenthesis
memes it's got that stupid picture of
that guy's face
making the face like ah i'm sure you've
seen it youtube has been
shielding this playlist more than
anything else in the entire website for
some reason
this playlist is god and it rules upon
this wretched land is he actually live
streaming right now sorry i just saw
dark toes is he playing with his feet
hey hey hey it's the leg man
no one really tunes into any streams i
do but
i feel like why not bother right
pewdiepie
come on felix it's
it's surprisingly difficult to just keep
your leg in a camera
because you have to try and tilt the
whole camera away from you
okay where was i yes the instant regret
play
clicking this how do i speak playlist
thank you this is my job for this i have
to
describe things you are welcome it gets
millions of views
and i am now going to react to this
playlist as a
poor attempt to get in recommended to
these videos so that i can get
millions of views without any form of
talent and original content oh he's
self-aware that's so funny
i'm gonna leave a like on this video
right now don't forget to buy the merch
as well
thank you now let's say let's get into
this playlist
shall we
[Music]
[Applause]
john white for the gold
[Music]
john white one more hit will it be
enough
front side perfect
[Applause]
pretty solid edit but did it make me
scrata but don't make me laugh
i mean literally don't that's the point
of the game
okay let's keep going
[Music]
stop the hammering stop the hammering
out there who's got a hammer
okay that one was good congratulations
but i didn't scratch that
get out of here do you know what that
means
[Music]
then let me teach you a lesson let me
guess
he's going to throw the glass but it's
going to hit someone else
[Music]
oh wow what is this dolan dark
[Applause]
they're too fast how do i supposed to
react to this
oh she just replayed the video yes
because it's literally six seconds and i
need to process what happened
[Applause]
i still don't understand my god so
annoying this is just annoying
people like this people like this [ __ ]
my god
hey guys this is barack to octavia and
the johns hopkins girls i want you to
know i love memes
i love them all right thanks thank you
cue the trump memes
drop it
[Music]
yeah my god
what's wrong with him
i love refrigerators oh my god random
this playlist sucks and you suck for
liking it okay
i'm gonna be the first one to say it
that's right and it's not for me to have
a contrarian opinion
it is my genuine duty to review this as
a meme reviewer
the way it truly needs to be reviewed
you are welcome
what do you want me to sit here and
laugh and be like
that was funny because i can do that
[Music]
i can't i literally can't
i can't even force myself
when you have it on your head you really
feel like you're suspended
so this is just pleasure for us watching
richard being tortured
oh oh he's having a man oh
the heights he'll go to oh are you all
right richard
[Music]
[Applause]
wow
you did it dolan dark you did it hooray
for you
good good for you an actual
apple ad you best be joking hey
what you doing on your computer what's a
computer
[Music]
oh my god what's a computer we're apple
we try to innovate in the future no one
will know but it can be
this is painful there's pain is
inflicted upon me with this playlist
that i can't articulate myself help me
[Music]
hey look a video longer than six seconds
how about that
everyone wow
wow a good one well done
it's actually so relatable whenever i
was in school i was always like all
right let's just get this done and then
you can go home and play video games
and look where that got me hooray yay
for me
all right what is this an unlisted video
wow
what's he doing
is he gonna get hit by a car no that was
a that was it that was all the memes
are you kidding me it's not funny
your shitty memes aren't funny unless
someone gets hurt
if he doesn't get hit by a car then
what's the point
what was the point of that seriously
have we fallen that low have we stooped
that low that
no one will even be close to death
then why is it funny why is it funny
then
what was funny about that nothing was
funny about that
nothing is funny unless someone gets
hurt
so my mom tried to be cute make these
little thanksgiving snacks here she saw
on uh
pinterest this is what they actually
came out like
oh that's great fine fine instant regret
clicking playlist you got me one time
what do you want an
award i will not laugh at the next one
yes
oh what a savage bus everybody
and now it leaves wow hey hooray well i
think that's a good time as any to end
it here
wow we sold it dab like this
hope you guys enjoyed this video if you
did leave a like and if you didn't like
make sure you leave a like as well
anyway also
make sure to subscribe everybody
check out the instant regret playlist
shout outs to that wonderful playlist
i'm now going to end this video with
something out of context because
literally anything out of context is
extremely hilarious
how about maybe a vsauce meme